(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Nessa aula, nós vamos falar sobre o procedimento
pós-leilão.
Então, vamos falar sobre tudo que você precisa
saber depois de participar de um leilão.
O que acontece, quais são os crâmites de
um leilão judicial.
O leilão, ele acontece com dia e hora
marcado, como a gente já falou anteriormente.
Esses horários estão previstos no edital do leilão,
basta que você veja o que o edital
está falando para saber qual vai ser o
dia e a hora.
A preferência da lei para os leilões judiciais,
é que o leilão judicial seja realizado de
forma online.
Então, vai ser aquele procedimento que a gente
falou lá no módulo 1.
Você vai se cadastrar no site do leiloeiro,
vai enviar toda a documentação que o leiloeiro
pede, a maioria deles pede que seja digitalizado
ou por meio de uma foto mesmo, carteira
de identidade, cpf, comprovante de residência e alguns
pedem que você assine um termo.
Então, você vai assinar esse termo e também
vai mandar digitalizado ou por meio de uma
foto.
Realizando esse cadastro, você está apto a se
habilitar a qualquer leilão que aquele leiloeiro faça.
Se habilitar, como a gente falou no começo
do curso, é nada mais do que apertar
um botão no site do leiloeiro, falando que
você concorda com as regras daquele lote específico.
Então, você concorda com as regras daquele imóvel
especificamente.
Isso significa se habilitar.
A partir do momento que você se habilita,
você está apto a dar lances.
Lembrando que você deve fazer o cadastro com
o máximo de antecedência possível e habilitação também.
Os leiloeiros proíbem que a habilitação ocorra uma
ou duas horas antes do leilão.
Então, não esqueça de se habilitar, porque se
você esquecer de se habilitar, você não vai
conseguir dar o lance no imóvel de seu
interesse.
Ocorrendo o leilão, em primeiro lugar acontece a
primeira praça.
Se a primeira praça for negativa, o leiloeiro
emite o auto de leilão negativo e o
imóvel segue automaticamente para a segunda praça.
Isso é, se na primeira praça não ocorrer
nenhum lance para aquele imóvel, o leiloeiro vai
comunicar ao juiz que realmente naquela praça não
teve nenhum lance, é feito pelo auto de
leilão negativo e o imóvel segue automaticamente para
a segunda praça, porque o edital já coloca
a primeira e segunda praça, a data e
horário da primeira e segunda praça.
Passando, então, para a segunda praça, se a
segunda praça for negativa, o leiloeiro emite outro
auto de leilão negativo e aí o juiz
vai decidir o que ele vai fazer com
aquele imóvel, como a gente já estudou em
uma aula específica.
O juiz pode aumentar o desconto, ele pode
mudar o leiloeiro ou ele pode pedir para
que o mesmo leiloeiro faça um novo leilão.
Isso vai ficar a critério do juiz.
Se tiver arrematação em primeira ou segunda praça,
então, se ocorrer uma arrematação na primeira praça,
o leiloeiro já faz esse auto de arrematação,
já envia o juiz e a segunda praça
ela não vai existir.
Agora, se na primeira praça não existe lance,
o leiloeiro faz o auto de leilão negativo,
comunica o juiz, mas o imóvel segue automaticamente
para a segunda praça.
E aí, se nessa segunda praça tiver lance,
aí sim o leiloeiro faz o auto de
arrematação e comunica o juiz que ocorreu uma
arrematação.
Esse auto de arrematação nada mais é do
que colocar a descrição do imóvel, o nome
do leiloeiro, o nome do juiz, as partes
que estavam envolvidas naquela execução, quem era o
exequente, ou seja, o credor, quem era o
executado, ou seja, o devedor, quem é o
arrematante, qual é o valor da arrematação, se
vai ser pago à vista ou se vai
ser pago a prazo.
Todas as condições de pagamento vão ficar estabelecidas
nesse auto de arrematação.
Ocorrendo a arrematação, o arrematante deve pagar o
valor em 24 horas.
Então, assim que encerra o procedimento leilão, começa
a ocorrer esse prazo de 24 horas para
que o arrematante faça o pagamento.
Então, é muito importante que você, quando decida
participar de um leilão, quando você decidir qual
é o lance máximo que você pode oferecer
naquele leilão, você já deixe esse dinheiro separado,
porque se esse dinheiro estiver em algum tipo
de investimento financeiro, pode ser que nesse prazo
de 24 horas você não consiga fazer o
resgate e o pagamento.
Então, é importante que você já deixe separado
e talvez já comunique ao seu banco, dependendo
do valor que você tem para pagamento diário
e dependendo do valor do imóvel, é interessante
que você já faça essa comunicação para que
não ocorra nenhum erro na hora que você
for tentar pagar um boleto de um valor
um pouco mais alto.
Você já pede essa autorização ao seu gerente
e fica tudo certo, você consegue fazer esse
pagamento tranquilamente.
O auto de arrematação, ele vai ser assinado
pelo leiloeiro, pelo arrematante e pelo juiz.
Então, o leiloeiro, ele produz esse auto de
arrematação, o arrematante vai ter 24 horas para
pagar, assim que o arrematante paga, envia os
comprovantes para o leiloeiro, o leiloeiro, ele manda
esse auto de arrematação já assinado por ele
e pede para que o arrematante assine esse
auto, que depois ele vai enviar esse auto
para o juiz, para que o juiz também
assine.
Atenção, há uma exceção aqui.
Em alguns casos, os leiloeiros, no momento que
você realiza os cadastros nos sites deles, vão
pedir para que você assine um termo de
concordância das regras daquele site, pode ser que
nesse termo, o leiloeiro, ele coloque poderes para
ele te representar tão somente na assinatura desse
auto de arrematação.
Então, quando o leiloeiro coloca isso, pode ser
que ele não envie o auto de arrematação
para o arrematante assinar, porque o arrematante concordou
nesse termo que o leiloeiro poderia representá-lo
tão somente para assinar o auto de arrematação.
Então, o leiloeiro pode assinar o auto de
arrematação no nome do arrematante nesses casos.
Fique atento, então, quando você assinar esse termo
de concordância, leia atentamente e veja se aquele
leiloeiro especificamente vai colocar essa regra, que aí
depois você não precisa assinar o auto de
arrematação.
Então, pode ser que você faça o pagamento,
fique esperando receber o auto de arrematação e
você não vai receber, simplesmente porque o leiloeiro
colocou no termo de concordância do site que
ele poderia te representar para assinar o auto
de arrematação.
Após a assinatura do auto de arrematação pelo
juiz, a arrematação é considerada perfeita, acabada e
recratável.
Ou seja, a gente falou que a regra
é que assinem o auto de arrematação o
leiloeiro, o arrematante e o juiz.
Em primeiro lugar, vai assinar o leiloeiro, o
leiloeiro envia para o arrematante, que devolve para
o leiloeiro e o próprio leiloeiro apresenta ao
juiz.
O juiz vai receber aquele auto de arrematação
e vai assinar aquele auto.
Então, a partir daquele momento, a arrematação é
considerada perfeita, acabada e recratável.
E é preciso que você saiba que a
partir da assinatura pelo juiz desse auto de
arrematação, o juiz ele vai abrir um prazo
e esse prazo é previsto em lei.
É um prazo de 10 dias úteis para
o executado alegar algum vício no procedimento do
leilão, como por exemplo, preço vil ou a
falta de intimação da penhora do imóvel.
A gente vai estudar na próxima aula quais
são os requisitos de intimação de penhora de
imóvel do leilão especificamente, do executado e de
quem mais tem que ser intimado sobre a
data do leilão.
Mas o que pode anular um leilão são
exatamente vícios como esse ou uma arrematação por
um preço vil.
Por isso que é importante que você saiba
que no leilão judicial, se você oferecer um
lance abaixo de 50% do valor da
avaliação judicial e não da avaliação do mercado,
esse lance pode ser considerado preço vil.
E é importante também que você lembre que
se o leiloeiro, ele não atualizar monetariamente o
valor do laudo de avaliação, você como interessado
em arrematar, deve realizar essa atualização monetária.
Você vai atualizar daquele jeito que ele ensinou
numa aula específica.
Vai usar aquele site Dr. Calc, vai colocar
o índice do criminal que você está pretendendo
arrematar o imóvel e vai pedir para que
o site atualize aquele valor.
E é sobre aquele valor atualizado que você
deve oferecer seu lance.
Então, seu lance não pode passar de 50
% do valor atualizado que você encontrar.
Lembre-se que você precisa fazer esse procedimento
se o leiloeiro não fizer.
Se o leiloeiro atualizar o valor, tudo bem,
você usa o valor que está no site
do leiloeiro.
Então, a partir do momento que o juiz
assina o laudo de arrematação, ele vai abrir
esse prazo.
E esse prazo é um prazo de 10
dias úteis, para que o executado possa alegar
algum vício.
Caso não ocorra alegação de vício, o arrematante
solicita ao juiz que seja expedida a carta
de arrematação e o mandado de emissão na
posse.
A carta de arrematação é o documento necessário
para o registro do imóvel em leilão judicial.
Não existe escritura de compra e venda.
Então, no leilão judicial não vai existir escritura
de compra e venda, e sim a carta
de arrematação.
A carta de arrematação é o documento necessário
para que o arrematante compareça ao cartório de
registro de imóveis, onde aquele imóvel está registrado,
para pedir que ocorra a transferência do imóvel
para o seu nome.
Então, aqui em leilão judicial, esquece a escritura
de compra e venda, que é o documento
que a gente está acostumado a ter na
implementação de uma compra e venda de um
imóvel.
Em leilão judicial, a escritura não existe, vai
ser a carta de arrematação.
E o mandado de emissão na posse é
aquele documento necessário para que o oficial de
justiça realize a desocupação no leilão judicial, como
a gente já estudou numa aula específica sobre
isso.
Se ocorrer a alegação de vício, o arrematante
pode desistir da arrematação, recebendo os valores que
pagou de arrematação e leiloeiro.
O arrematante também pode desistir se provar nos
10 dias úteis seguintes ao leilão a existência
de ônus reais ou gravames não mencionados no
edital.
Então, vamos entender isso aqui.
Em primeiro lugar, o juiz assinou o auto
de arrematação, abriu esses 10 dias úteis.
Se o executado alegar que ocorreu algum vício
naquele leilão, é perfeitamente possível que o arrematante
fale a partir dessa alegação dele.
Olha, juiz, eu quero desistir dessa arrematação, eu
quero ter de volta tudo que eu paguei
a título de arrematação e comissão do leiloeiro
e esse é um direito do arrematante.
Então, o juiz vai devolver o que o
arrematante pagou a título de comissão de leiloeiro
e lance devidamente corrigido.
Se o tempo necessário até devolução puder passar
por alguma correção, porque pode ser que essa
devolução aconteça imediatamente, aquele seu valor ele nem
seja corrigido porque exatamente a devolução aconteceu de
forma muito rápida, nem virou um mês necessário
para atualizar aquele valor.
E o arrematante também pode desistir se dentro
desses 10 dias úteis, após a arrematação, ele
comprovar que existiu algum ônus ou algum gravame
que não foi especificado em edital.
A gente sempre bateu na tecla aqui no
curso que você, como interessado em arrematar, deve
pesquisar todos os ônus do imóvel através da
matrícula do imóvel, pesquisar débitos de IPTU, débitos
de condomínio.
Então, o ideal é que você não precise
recorrer a essa desistência porque você descobriu algo
após o leilão.
Mas se você descobrir algo que não estava
especificado no edital do leilão, que não estava
visível na matrícula do imóvel e que você
não teve conhecimento anteriormente, você pode sim pedir
para desistir do leilão judicial.
Essa é uma exclusividade da lei para o
leilão judicial.
Só se aplica aqui, então fique atento a
isso.
Faça todas as suas verificações para que você
não precise recorrer a isso.
Mas saiba que se após o leilão você
descobrir algo que não estava no edital, que
você não teve viciência, você poderá sim desistir
da arrematação.
Isso é uma exceção porque, como a gente
sempre falou aqui no curso, a arrematação, o
lance, ele é irretratável, mas a lei te
coloca essa segurança aqui.
Sobre a possibilidade do executado alegar algum vício
e o arrematante desistir, é preciso que você,
como arrematante, saiba que existe uma inovação do
Código de Processo Civil e agora a lei
estipula uma multa para o executado que realizar
a alegação de vício com o objetivo de
fazer o arrematante desistir da arrematação.
Essa multa tem um percentual de até 20
% do valor do bem, mas perdas e
danos.
Quem receberia essa multa se o arrematante desistir
não é o arrematante, porque o arrematante não
vai ter prejuízo, afinal, ele vai receber o
valor do lance e o valor da comissão
do leiloeiro de volta devidamente corrigido.
Quem vai receber essa multa de 20%
é o exequente, é o credor que estava
levando aquele imóvel a leilão, porque ele foi
o grande prejudicado.
Afinal de contas, ele teve que esperar por
alguns anos para que o imóvel fosse a
leilão e, quando o imóvel foi a leilão,
o executado fez uma alegação para o arrematante
desistir, simplesmente com esse objetivo, sem nenhum fundamento
aquela alegação.
Então, se o arrematante desistir, o grande prejudicado
é o exequente, é o credor.
Então, o credor que recebe essa multa.
O que você, como arrematante de um leilão
judicial, precisa saber é que a lei agora
é muito favorável para que o executado não
fique entrando com recursos sem nenhum fundamento.
Isso antes do Código Processo Civil de 2015
existia, porque a lei não colocava essa disposição
de multa para um recurso desse tipo, então
era comum que o quer dizer, aquele recurso
que não tem fundamento nenhum, que é só
para atrasar o procedimento do leilão.
E a lei mudou em 2015, a lei
agora é muito mais para o arrematante e
a lei colocou essa disposição de multa de
20%.
O que significa na prática?
É muito raro que, hoje em dia, um
executado faça algum tipo de alegação sem que
ele tenha nenhum fundamento, porque, se ele fizer
isso, ele pode ser multado em 20%.
Então, ele não quer sair devendo mais do
que ele já estava devendo.
Então, geralmente, o executado, ele só faz uma
alegação quando ele realmente acredita naquilo que ele
está falando, quando ele realmente acredita que teve
um vício, que pode ser um preso vil
ou uma falta de intimação.
Mas você, como arrematante, deve saber também que
você realizou todas as análises necessárias para participar
daquele leilão.
Então, você deve entrar naquele leilão quando você
tiver segurança do que você está fazendo.
Então, se o executado fizer uma alegação dessa,
você, como arrematante, que vai ter segurança de
todo o procedimento que você analisou, você não
deve temer esse recurso, porque esse recurso, ele
vai ser julgado pelo juiz e o juiz
vai decidir se realmente aquilo tem fundamento ou
não.
Se ele decidir que tem fundamento, você, como
arrematante, vai ter de volta tudo o que
você pagou.
Valor do lance e comissão do leiloeiro.
Se ele decidir que não tem fundamento, aí,
realmente, você, como arrematante, vai ter direito à
carta de arrematação e o mandado de admissão
na posse.
A minha opinião é que você não deve
temer isso.
Se o executado entrar com algum tipo de
alegação tentando anular o leilão e você fez
toda a verificação necessária para participar daquele leilão,
continue com aquele leilão.
Espere um pouco até que o juiz decida
sobre aquela alegação, porque, provavelmente, o juiz vai
julgar que aquela alegação, ela é improcedente.
Então, que o leilão foi todo correto e,
realmente, que o arrematante, ele tem direito à
carta de arrematação e o mandado de admissão
na posse.
Lembrando que, se o juiz julgar procedente essa
alegação do executado, você, como arrematante, não tem
prejuízo.
Você recebe o valor da comissão do leiloeiro
e o valor do lance devidamente atualizado.
Então, vamos lá.
O juiz vai julgar a alegação de vício.
Caso entenda que o executado está correto, quer
dizer, caso o juiz entenda que, realmente, ocorreu
um vício no procedimento daquele leilão, ele vai
anular o leilão e o arrematante recebe tudo
o que pagou devidamente corrigido.
Até esse momento, o arrematante só vai ter
pago o valor do lance e comissão do
leiloeiro.
Caso o juiz entenda que o executado não
está correto e fez a alegação somente para
protelar, ou seja, somente para atrasar o procedimento,
ele vai determinar o prosseguimento do processo e
pode aplicar essa multa de 20% que
a gente acabou de falar.
Nesse caso 2, ou seja, se o juiz
julgar que a alegação é improcedente, o arrematante
também deve fazer esse requerimento da carta de
arrematação e mandado de missão na posse.
Lembrando que eu vou deixar aqui nessa aula
esse modelo de pedido de requerimento pós leilão
judicial, ou seja, para que seja expedida a
carta de arrematação e o mandado de missão
na posse.
O arrematante, então, em posse da carta de
arrematação, ele vai receber o cartório de registro
de imóvel competente para dar a entrada no
registro do imóvel em seu nome.
E a desocupação vai ser realizada pelo oficial
de justiça, como a gente já estudou em
aula específica sobre desocupação de um imóvel em
leilão judicial.